foreign
we have a big development in the
investigation of Alec Baldwin after that
deadly shooting on the set of the movie
rust prosecutors have dropped
involuntary involuntary manslaughter
charges against him at least for now he
was holding the gun when it went off
killing cinematographer Helena Hutchins
Jonathan vigliata shows us why the
charges against the star have now been
dismissed
were you were in the room when the lady
when someone was assaulting the gun Alec
Baldwin was rehearsing a scene for rust
when his gun discharged on the film's
New Mexico set in October 2021 it was
loaded with live ammunition it should
have been a cold gun with no rounds
inside or dummy rounds Baldwin has
insisted he never pulled the trigger of
the weapon that killed Helena Hutchins
and injured director Joel Souza
prosecutors initially argued otherwise
this was a negligent discharge of a
firearm because he pulled that trigger
that was Santa Fe District Attorney Mary
Carmack altwes speaking with CBS News in
January but on Thursday special
prosecutors overseeing the case said new
facts were revealed that demand further
investigation and forensic analysis
leading them to dismiss involuntary
manslaughter charges against Baldwin
they added the decision does not absolve
Baldwin of criminal culpability and
charges may be filed I was very
surprised when I heard the charges had
been dropped and then I was even more
surprised when I read what the reasoning
seems to be CBS News legal analyst Ricky
Clement pointed to new reports which
suggests the gun in question may have
been modified before it was delivered to
set what we've learned is that if this
gun had in fact been modified and that
it could go
without someone pulling the trigger is
that the prosecutors and their first
investigation was not thorough
involuntary manslaughter charges have
not been dropped against Hannah
Gutierrez Reid who was in charge of
weapons on the set
[Music]
at least I was her lawyers say they
expect her to be exonerated and
meanwhile assistant director David Halls
who inspected the gun before giving it
to Baldwin has pleaded no contest to a
misdemeanor charge negligent use of a
deadly weapon for CBS mornings I'm
Jonathan Vigliotti
well Alec Baldwin has been very
consistent in that he didn't he says he
didn't pull the trigger yeah but then
you had experts say the gun couldn't
have fired without it being pulled and
now you hear that it may have been
modified it makes you think why was that
information revealed in the beginning it
might have been tricky to figure it out
technically technically and I think we
all assume you might not have thought
you pulled the trigger but maybe out of
habit or instinct or something or it was
an air trigger you may not remember it
but you might have right or a hair
trigger another question is who modified
the gun yes that's the case other
question is how did a live bullet get in
that gun still so many questions but the
bottom line is she's no longer with us
and that still makes this a very very
tragic story yeah he's got a young son
and a husband that's still very
difficult right about that